à la sortie de rerson une file de
voiture longue de plus d'un kilomètre la
ville est devenue une cible permanente
des forces russes depuis leur départ il
y a deux semaines menacé ses habitants
fuient dans la précipitation
on ne peut pas faire autrement trois ou
quatre jours après leur départ de Herson
de violents bombardements ont commencé
beaucoup de gens ont été tués blessés
les Russes tirent sur le centre-ville
les maisons tout
la bouffe avant-hier une frappe à
toucher notre maison quatre appartements
brûlés les fenêtres ont volées en éclat
nous ne pouvons pas rester là vendredi
la ville a connu son bombardement le
plus meurtrier 15 civils sont morts face
à cette stratégie de la terreur Kiev
évacue les patients des hôpitaux des
trains spéciaux ont aussi été mis en
place dans l'urgence les habitants sont
nombreux à choisir l'exode
de manière chaotique ils n'ont pas
forcément de cible précise ils ne vise
pas que des cibles militaires
les Russes visent aussi les
infrastructures énergétiques mais
l'électricité a pu être rétabli dans la
ville selon les autorités